vamos por la vida viendo líneas por
todas partes entonces lo que yo voy a
hacer en este vídeo es pensar en las
diferencias que hay entre lo que es un
segmento de línea una línea y lo que es
un rayo y ver las versiones geométricas
puras de esto ahora un segmento de línea
es lo que muchos de nosotros conocemos o
asociamos a una línea en nuestra vida
diaria entonces un segmento de línea es
algo de este estilo conocido como una
línea recta pero la razón por la que le
llamamos segmento es porque tiene un
punto de inicio y tiene un punto final
entonces vamos por ahí viendo muchas
líneas y estas son en realidad segmentos
de líneas cuando las vemos desde un
punto de vista geométrico puro ahora sé
que dibuje esto un poco chueco debe
estar completamente recto este es un
segmento de línea el segmento de línea
se basa en tener un punto de inicio y un
punto final ahora una línea si la pinzas
en el sentido simétrico puro no tiene
fin no tiene un punto de partida no
tiene un punto final
las líneas siguen y siguen infinitamente
en ambas direcciones entonces una línea
se ve de esta forma y para mostrar que
sigue y sigue infinitamente en una
dirección por ejemplo en estas ponemos
esta flecha y para otra dirección
ponemos esta otra flecha ahora yo yo
jamás me he encontrado con algo que siga
y siga infinitamente pero en matemáticas
en matemáticas lo elegante la magia que
existe es que podemos pensar en estas
cosas abstractas entonces el concepto
geométrico puro de línea es una cosa que
sigue y sigue infinitamente en ambas
direcciones
un rayo es algo intermedio un rayo tiene
un punto de partida bien definido pero
luego de ahí parte una línea que seguirá
y seguirá por siempre entonces un rayo
puede iniciar en este punto y de ahí
parte las líneas la flecha indicando que
seguirá infinitamente eso es un rayo
sabiendo esto entremos al módulo en la
página de la canacar a mí
hagamos el ejercicio donde reconocemos
segmentos de líneas líneas y rayos creo
ya será fácil identificarlos basándonos
en la clasificación que hicimos entonces
abro la página del módulo aquí está muy
bien iniciamos que tenemos una figura
con flechas en ambos extremos nos indica
que continuará por siempre entonces
tenemos una línea veamos acá y está
feliz es una línea siguiente muy bien
aquí tenemos igual flechas en ambos
extremos nos indica que continuará y
continuará en ambas direcciones entonces
tenemos una línea
perfecto aquí tenemos una flecha una
flecha entonces esto se va hasta el
infinito en esa dirección y tiene un
punto de partida bien definido por lo
tanto ahí inicia luego sigue y sigue por
siempre que es a pues es un rayo
si parte del punto y sigue en esa
dirección infinitamente veamos
cáritas él es perfecto ahora aquí
tenemos un punto de partida y un punto
final o puede ser este el punto de
partida y el otro el punto final por lo
tanto tenemos un segmento de línea
veamos cáritas él es perfecto creo ya
hicimos suficientes ejercicios y creo ya
se entendió el sentido geométrico puro
de esto te invito a que entres a la
página de requián a quedar a mí y hagas
algunos ejercicios hasta pronto